i'm a fan of bernie sanders as a person
hear me out hear me out where i'm going
with this
i i i had a communist stunt i've had a
lot of communists i probably interviewed
six or seven communists right sometimes
that's what pat does on the weekend
yeah comments are fun i would love to
know how many of those videos were
pulled i'm guessing none none of them
they're all on absolutely so surprising
to me
what a great research we just did in two
seconds she's right none of them have
been pulled but i have these commies on
and i interview them and i'm curious to
know what they think and i respect the
ones that are true believers the ones
that are just phony trying to sound like
they're you know you'll catch them very
quickly within 30 minutes you're full of
[ __ ] you're not really what are you
talking about right okay so you're just
acting up but some of the guys you talk
you're like okay cool i respect it i
think bernie's a true believer you know
what's confusing to me with bernie why i
think a bernie and
a bernie n and aoc in the most strangest
way are necessary let me explain why
aoc the other day called that not the
other day about five weeks ago called
that pelosi saying congress you know
people in politics shouldn't be able to
you know uh trade best because yeah
because we have insider informants just
like no i'm i'm on invest you can't tell
me anything i'm going to do it right but
by the way other people are now coming
in and somebody not jim jordan who was a
guy that maybe even jim jordan who
called that pelosi recently not jim
jordan the other
there
guy
meadows i don't know i don't know who
was pull up to see who just called that
pelosi here's where i'm going with this
do you know the medicine azt
azt was for ages i only know sudafed
that's all i have okay that's right but
azt
azt was a
pill they came up with for aids which by
the way some claim
330 000 people died from this like
remember accutane had a lot of side
effects like this is like times you know
a lot higher people died from taking
aids medication taking aids medication
but here's the part
when they built this medicine when they
finally came out with this medicine do
you know how much it cost them to make
each pill
two cents
is what it costs them to make penny
selling it for a hundred bucks a
ten thousand dollars
and and guess guess who was for it a guy
named fauci yeah so a person that
shouldn't be for
what fauci is doing is in a random way
i think an aoc if a and a bernie sanders
if they come together and they realize
that this guy is simply supporting
big pharma
aoc and bernie could play a very
important role in a fouchy no longer
being here because bernie keeps talking
about what what does bernie say how
could you charge so much for this
medicine how could you charge so much
your numbers are
free college do you realize that's the
billionaire this thing calls 60 cents to
make but they're selling you four
thousand dollars okay bernie i agree
with you i'm with you you're right keep
pushing the envelope because the guy
that's endorsing and allowing these
things to happen because here's what
happens with them they got 20 different
products that's being pitched hey this
could be the cure for this but i'm only
looking at the five that i want to deal
with because it's got i'm not spending
time investigating these other ones so
my resources are being used for this
five but these other 15 they're cheap
cost effective
less side effects less testimony no not
right now maybe a year from now maybe
two years from now maybe three years
from now so i think the possibility of
fauci getting fired
could be high and in the most random
weirdest way i think the people that can
help that happen is bernie and aoc
the thing is though bernie and aoc and
you're you're right i mean these are not
they should not be a big pharma allies
they should be sounding the alarm on all
this stuff but the problem is is that
they're benefiting from the chaos the
division and the panic again
part of all of this is is panic right
you know because
there there are treatments available now
we shouldn't be panicked now this is not
march of 2020. there are treatments
available there are monoclonals there
are drugs that we know yes ivermectin
has been used successfully i know joe
rogan took a bunch of hits but it's true
there have been numerous studies on that
there's hydroxy which people have taken
there's other treatments that are
available for people now
if you take that panic away if you take
that division away communism cannot
thrive
you can it can't it needs that because
you have to believe that the state is
for it you have to believe that it's the
state
it's what fauci says these people are
sheep they walk around they're like i
don't know what to do do i double mass
do i shield do i triple mass they need
that so if you remove that and all of a
sudden aoc starts questioning big pharma
people will start realizing well wait a
minute was this a lot of this did a lot
of this have to do with money did a lot
of this have to do with suppression of
treatments did we really need to be
panicking for this long
condition i want to see what you're
going to see i'm going to push back and
see what you're going to say
so
um how many people on the right would
like to see a third party
none
on the right no i mean i mean listen
like let me ask you a question yes there
are people but it's not in a majority
because they know that a third party
will enable a democrat success but now
let me ask the other question how many
people on the left would like to see a
third party you don't think so okay well
this is my
idea on what i'm thinking that i i do
believe both sides want to see a third
party hear me out hear me out here
i think
aoc
is sick and tired of these democrats
that are getting in the way
and i think aoc is convinced they're
never going to buy in to what she's
bought into ever
and i think aoc is eventually going to
sit there and say you know what i'm loud
enough
i got a bigger mic i get more likes i
get more eyeballs i have more followers
i got the younger audience you don't i'm
sexier i'm more attractive i talk better
i speak better and i'm a true believer
and i'm gonna get these guys to be
convinced we need a third party so
what's the third party a third party say
democratic socialist party comes out
let's just say i'm just throwing this
out there yeah speculation right
i think
where where that 12
of america wants to go to that i think
america america's run by 12 percent i
don't think america is run by anything
else but the 12 percent in the middle
east i think i think 12 runs america i
think all the other guys are just
wasting time 12 percent of america runs
america period it's a 12 that was like
you know what i don't know about trump
let me go over here it's the 12 percent
i said you know i don't know about obama
let's go to trump that's the twelve
percent the twelve percent
everybody else is just talking ohio
michigan wisconsin i'm talking 12
is the one that runs the country
i think if it gets to the tipping point
where these guys are eventually sitting
there having a strategy session because
i think the four you know what it called
the four the four girls what's the the
i think if those guys are sitting behind
closers and saying hey girls
you know what let's do it let's go let's
go all out here's what we should do now
you're shaking your head no i i see
we're going with this i'm telling you
right now i actually think that's good
for america
i actually think it's good for america
if some of those guys go and some of the
people from the right go because i think
the left what do you mean right i think
the right from the right they're like
screw this i want to be a libertarian
i'm going to go independent let's push
let's actually bank on bringing a ron
paul not a ron paul a uh
uh
uh the founder of the internet what's
the guy um
the guy that goes out not al gore
ross pro let's get the next ross perot
true believer a shamath type of guy a
you know person like that's like screw
republicans screw democrats i'm an
independent i'm a real independent that
can make sense that's a salesperson that
can get you to say this makes sense like
you're saying rand paul doesn't he's so
intellectual that he can't speak the
language of the average person
believe it or not i think there's gonna
be
some positive happening
from some of these socialists because
they're not for big pharma and and if
you have to look at enemies like if you
can if you sit there right now make a
list of enemies like concerns like if
you you know uh uh if you sit there you
got you got i don't know if you guys got
kids or no shoes you're one kid one
could really hardly two years old that's
the name of your book you're hartley
baby who are you writing down over there
you wrote an enemy down no no no i wrote
a little note for myself he's too
fantastic he's too perceptive i got a
nine eight five and a six and a half
month old baby oh my god right now
you're not exhausted oh
you vampires my eyes don't see anything
but anyway so so here's here's where i'm
going with this i think those guys
are ambitious enough to believe that and
i think if we look at the current
enemies look at the list of top 10
enemies like you're raising kids and you
say who are the enemies of me raising
kids what school am i going to put them
teachers like weird things you think as
a enemy of a kid a teacher a friend a
coach a sunday school teacher like you
got to be kind of keeping your eyes open
to see who's there right uh
son of a friends you know kids like some
of that stuff okay who are the long-term
enemies of america of us okay so one is
silicon valley you have to put that on
that list
uh two is what let's say socialist okay
fine
big pharma has got to be in the top ten
okay china lobbyists got to be in the
top 10 china is at the number one spot
right you got to put russia's probably
in the top 10. iran's probably in the
top 15.
but you have to put big farm on that
list so now how do you play against them
the way the way this happens on holding
them accountable
is when both sides kind of team up and
say you know what no it took you five
cents to make this ten thousand dollars
is just too much abuse and all these
health insurance costs you guys keep on
increasing i have a lot of employees
every year i'm paying more health
insurance and i have the
the friction with the employee well my
health insurance is going up i'm like
dude i didn't increase your health
insurance 30
this is what's increasing the health
insurance i think there is certain
things that those two sides can disrupt
big pharma i don't know i may be maybe i
had too much sudafed this morning
i don't know what it is shout outs
i think you have a very valid point
right here everything you're saying
anyways i may be i may be confused and
lost but i think my point makes sense so
here's the problem with that though if
that segment of the left you're talking
about the aoc is the bernie sanders if
they're going to come out and criticize
big pharma they're going to come at it
from the perspective of the solution is
socialized medicine the solution for
government the solution is medicare for
all that's a problem that's going to
appeal
it'll appeal to some it will enrage
others also they're going to have a
really hard time
doing that because they need the support
if you're going to criticize big pharma
you also have to criticize the fda you
also have to criticize collusion that
goes on between government organizations
and institutions and these
pharmaceutical companies and how really
intrinsically linked they often are
they're not going to do that so the
right is the people on the right who
criticize big pharma will come in and
say
well they'll talk about profits but
they'll talk about the answers to a lot
of this is innovation is choice is
freedom is opportunity the people from
the left who criticize big pharma are
going to say well they're all about
profit and the way that we fix this is
that we remove profit and then you have
socialized medicine where people are
waiting you know lines and lines and
lines and you have government deciding
for you instead of big pharma deciding
for you what you need you need this you
need that you're going to have
government deciding it for you and yeah
maybe it'll be less expensive but i
don't know that the outcome is any
different so
i think it's very tricky i don't my my
question is always
how much support i know aoc is popular
she's on tick tock she's talking to
young people most of what she says to me
makes absolutely no sense if i mean i
encourage her to come and sit and have a
debate with me i think it would be
really great television most of what she
says can easily be pushed back on and
makes very little sense but who how much
of the country actually is is going to
support someone like that because i do
think there are a lot of people who will
and a lot of people who won't but my
concern is
what does that number look like what is
that percentage are we now seeing in
america where these mandates and this
way of life and this shift towards
socialism is increasingly much more
popular so that someone like an aoc she
ultimately decides one day she wants to
run for president actually has a chance
and what does that look like i don't
know i think no i don't i think
we're really very split right now in the
united states of america and you all you
need to do is you know what everybody
out there take a trip to new york city
and spend three days there and then come
out to you know miami head out to to
dallas texas and just see the two
completely different worlds we're living
in
but i don't i don't know how helpful it
is i don't know i mean i always think
splitting up political parties has an
advantage because you force people to
actually stand for something
um but the allegiances will be the same
right like aoc needs the teachers unions
the the establishment democrat needs the
teachers unions aoc needs government
agencies the democrat establishment
needs government agencies that's why
these third parties don't work
oftentimes because they're out there on
their own they have to break all of
those ties and then and then who's
funding them where are their donations
coming from the people could work i
don't know well i mean that's that's the
good part because neither bernie nor aoc
are getting checks from the big from big
pharma again that's the part where you
got to respect where it's a lot of
smaller guys are giving them the money
right the government though
i totally get it but the part is it
doesn't matter if if the two if the two
groups can unify on one enemy one is
going to pitch this is why the
government's got to take care of it the
other one's going to say no
you got to make the barrier to entry to
compete a lot low because these guys are
not helping the smaller companies come
up and compete against advisor compete
against this guy it's pretty much a
controller at the top right so meaning
for the longest time
tell me one automaker that competed in
america when's the last time in
automaker competed in america when's the
last time you know how many years it's
been do you know how many years it's
been that a new automaker comes out and
whoops some ass
no no no prior to that where to tesla
you're saying who was it naming delorean
an american company yeah
yeah an american company comes out and
competing other than the big three other
than gm chrysler yeah tell me one nobody
i can't even think of do you realize how
many years that is so what happens with
tesla what's the best thing that
happened with america elon musk tesla
comes out disrupts the automotive
industry they're they're scared they're
sitting there saying holy freaking molly
uh biden and his administration holds an
eevee meeting and at the white house
they invite chrysler they invite ford
they invite gm and the only guy they
don't invite is the guy that disrupted
the ev
elon musk so how necessary is an elon
musk very necessary but he's not a
politician
so here's the thing but i'm saying but
i'm saying opposing i'm saying if the
two like like but elon musk is also not
a republican right right right right is
probably independent he's not a
republican you can't sit there he's a
republican right all i'm saying is
i think
the people on the right anything they
say about big pharma the left is going
to say what yeah they're going to say
something like that well how about the
fact that you know ruber you know
murdoch and what fox is doing but if an
aoc and a bernie says that then
democrats have to sit there and say oh
maybe bernie's right yeah this is true
this is like this whole thing right now
the confusion with
my body my choice right what is my body
my choice right
my body my choice is what is hey if i
want to get an abortion it's up to me
you're right look at the hypocrisy in
the last 12 months yeah you're right my
body
my choice
and that that's a debate
that's a little bit different too um
because and people always say well my
body my choice you're right there is a
lot of hypocrisy from people who would
argue who would support abortion but
then would turn around and tell you to
you know the vast mandates are totally
legit but the difference with that is
also because people will come out and
say well that involves another person
you know if you're pregnant that
involves another life that's a whole
different pro-life argument that would
have to be brought in and you know
debated but i understand what you're
saying but i don't think
i think that what you would be
suggesting would imply that these
politicians are principled and don't
have those underlying ties to
establishment x y and z throughout like
i don't think aoc is someone who's out
there you saw a year ago i remember she
was making headlines she was going after
pelosi they were like the division the
left is falling apart she
took two steps forward she fell right
back in line because she understands
that there's a lot of power that comes
from being part of something she can
criticize them
i i don't know i don't know if what
you're talking i think there are people
who can break the system right but i
firmly believe that those people come
from outside of washington dc not inside
yeah to me
i see bernie and aoc that they believe
what they're talking about bernie more
than aoc because bernie got married and
you know his honeymoon was in russia i
mean did you go to russia on your
honeymoon i didn't go to russia he
believes it but he's not he's not living
his lifestyle doesn't ascribe to true
what i mean he's he's got a ton of money
yes
and and and he he does have a lot of
money but he's also a guy
that in the area of going up against big
pharma i'm just telling you
he will play a very important role
in beating those guys he's very very
important in that area okay
you and i don't have to agree on hey you
don't like tyler i don't like to uh
whatever kids but you like him i don't
like him whatever i like adam you don't
like adam whatever but if you and i
agree and say look that guy right there
i don't agree with that he does this
this this but that one thing
i can i can go on that one thing with
you and you open them and say look folks
bernie here and i don't agree on 99 of
things but let me tell you the one thing
that we agree on there's no way in the
world medication costs a thousand
dollars when they make it for pennies
that's the one area bernie is it fair to
say we agree or not i say i think we
want to see that we want to see it it's
never going to happen it's never going
to happen because that's not how the
size of the political aisle works i read
this book called the power of positive
thinking
you're very positive and i
understand it sounds great that people
would be able to focus on an issue come
together on different sides of an aisle
attack that issue
they're just it's not going to happen
because they they see it as a domino
effect and they're going in such
drastically different directions
solution wise that's the problem my
solutions are over here your solutions
are over here never to come and meet in
the center for any reason um
i just don't think it's going to happen
but we can agree to disagree on that one
i'll watch i'll i'll be i want front row
tickets and popcorn if that starts
bernie if if you want to talk big pharma
please you have the mic come on here
let's talk he's fine
big pharma i wouldn't be surprised if
bernie shows up one of these days so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye
[Music]